this is here with register nurse re and
calm and in this video I want to go over
some tips on how to deal with those
patients who have difficult veins as a
nurse it is inevitable that on a daily
basis you're going to encounter those
patients that are difficult to draw
blood from or start IVs and there's
various reasons that this happened some
reasons could be your patients just
severely dehydrated so those veins are
not popping up or they have severe
cardiac or renal disease so what I want
to do is I want to give you some tips on
how to deal with those things the first
thing what you want to keep in mind is
that usually on most patients they're
gonna have something for you to use for
drawing blood or starting an IV even
though it doesn't look like it initially
or the patient tells you no I'm a really
hard stick but usually most patients
will have something that you can access
so with these patients you're really
going to be going by palpation of that
vein rather than actually seeing it like
you know on patients who are healthy
they do a lot of cardiovascular exercise
those veins are nice and superficial at
the surface and once you apply that
tourniquet they just pop up there but on
patients who have bad veins that doesn't
happen you'll put the tourniquet on
there and those veins really just don't
pop up as great as someone who has those
nice and gorgeous aims so you have to
know number one the location of your
veins and in the adult they're usually
the same across the board like the
median cubital the accessor area
cephalic you're just going to find those
in the same location so be familiar
where you can find these veins second
what you have to do is you have to
practice filling veins and veins feel
very unique compared to other structures
in the arm so what I like to do is I
like to take my index finger and I like
to start filling all throughout my arm
the front the back everywhere I can
especially on these patients whose veins
just aren't popping up because veins
have a very unique feel in that they're
squishy but bouncy and once you get the
feel of what they feel like you will
never confuse it for other structures
and arm but whenever you're first
starting out it's very foreign because
you know I remember starting out and
filling on an arm I'm like what is that
is that a vein and
and my preceptor be like no that's like
a tendon or a ligament I'll be like oh
okay
so what you can do what worked for me is
that I would take a tourniquet apply it
to my own arm and I would feel my veins
or I would use my husband or a friend or
a family member who ever was healthy who
had great veins and I would just feel
throughout the arm and get comfortable
with how that vein would feel next you
want to use two things you want to use a
tourniquet and gravity both of these
things are going to benefit you greatly
when trying to start a V s or draw blood
on these people who have difficult veins
because it's like this same concept with
the water hose once you kink that water
hose and put a lot of pressure on it
what is that water hose start to do it
starts to swell that's what these veins
are going to do because we need that
once we go in there to palpate to fill
that swollen squishy bouncy vein so we
can stick it so what I like to do is I
like to put the tourniquet on the upper
arm not too tight but not too loose just
alright have a patient drop the arm by
the side and pump out this just open and
close that hand over and over and this
gives a time for that blood to pull in
that lower part of the arm so you can
increase your chances of getting a vein
and the thing is it's really amazing how
taking the time to just do those two
simple things really does work now I
worked in a stress lab for many years
and right off the bat whenever the
patient comes to you for the tests they
have to have an IV and I would get a lot
of patients who would tell me you know
people hardly ever can stick me
successfully it takes multiple tries I
just don't have anything and you know
looking at their arm initially they
really didn't have anything but once I
apply that tourniquet use gravity for my
benefit it was just simply amazing what
actually popped up and was available for
me to use they would shock me and shock
the patient and we usually get it first
try and the patient be like wow that
never happens so always try to use those
two simple things to help you with
drawing blood and getting IVs and lastly
you know sometimes you can put the
tourniquet on you can use gravity all
day you can palpate all day stick the
patient you're just not getting anything
and this is where you need to
use those outside resources there's vane
lots available maybe your unit has one
that can help illuminate the vein so you
can easily find it or in other
situations depending on what you have
available at your facility you can have
ultrasound [ __ ] ultrasound the arm find
that vein and stick them for IVs and
places I've worked we've had that and
I'll share a story with you we had a
patient coming in for a stress test and
they were like you know I need a central
line to have this test and you know
going and getting a central line is
expensive for the patient there's risk
of infection and all these issues just
the HAP like this for our tests really
an IV is the best route so we called
ultrasound they came up they ultrasound
the arm and they found a vein it was
deep down in the bend of the arm but
there was a vein there starting IV got
it person had their stress test and we
saved them from having to get a central
line and that was great so always look
and see what your Hospital has available
for those situations that do arise but
if you do have a patient you know you're
just not getting anything on them
they're gonna be there because they're
really sick they need a lot of treatment
with IV fluids you probably want to get
with the physician explain what's going
on because I patient it may be a
candidate for a central line and do that
and said okay so that is what I'd like
to do whenever I have those patients who
have those difficult veins and I hope
those tips help you out and be sure to
check out my other videos on how to
start IVs and tips on how to deal with
those rolling veins and things like that
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos